it will soon be three years since the
first reports emerged from the Chinese
city of Wuhan about a deadly new
respiratory disease the World Health
organization's coronavirus dashboard
provides a stark illustration of how
covid-19 has affected all of us hundreds
of thousands of cases are reported every
day with well over half a billion
documented so far no corner of the globe
has been left untouched
here's a breakdown of where we are now
in the pandemic which provides some
Clues to what the future might hold
the first year of the pandemic was about
unprecedented changes streets emptied
more or less overnight countries all
over the world closed borders and locked
down
masking up became compulsory there were
no vaccines and because Health Care
Professionals had little experience with
the disease catching it was a terrifying
proposition
as the first vaccines were rolled out at
the end of that first pandemic year
around 90 million cases of covid-19 had
been reported worldwide since then over
seven times that number of people have
tested positive for the disease and
experts estimate there have been many
many more unconfirmed cases
at the peak of the Omicron variant surge
last January the highest number of cases
in the pandemic so far over 20 million
people worldwide were testing positive
for the disease every week
throughout the pandemic deaths worldwide
unsurprisingly have reflected infection
worldwide a series of waves struck the
planet though different countries
suffered differently at different times
a retrospective reveals at least one
detectable pattern it was a simple and
devastating equation when the number of
cases Rose and fell in a new wave the
number of deaths followed a couple of
weeks later
the deadliest wave so far peaked in
early 2021 when in one terrible week
over a hundred thousand people died
worldwide
but the equation has changed somewhat
since the massive Omicron wave early
this year large numbers of people are
still getting sick but on average fewer
are dying
the changing relationship between case
rates and death tolls is at least in
part due to another Factor widespread
vaccination
so far over 12 and a half billion doses
of vaccines have gone into arms all over
the world significant percentages of
populations in the Americas Europe and
Asia are now fully vaccinated though
there's still a lot to do in Africa
the biggest vaccination Drive in history
is not all on its own been enough to
stop the continued spread of covid-19
but coupled with the immunity induced
and many people through wide scale
exposure experts say it's brought the
day when we declare the pandemic at an
end a lot nearer and save tens of
millions of lives
of more let's speak to Nina Schwalbe
she's a vaccination and immunization
expert and a principal fellow uh dealing
at the United Nations International
Institute for Global health she's
attending the World Health Summit that's
taking place in Berlin right now thanks
for being with us
in almost three years now since we
learned about the first covid case uh
where do things stand now are we how
close are we to seeing an end to this
pandemic uh thanks for the question and
thanks for having me here unfortunately
until everybody's vaccinated we really
won't be able to call an end to this
pandemic we still have people dying we
have thousands of people dying around
the world each day and uh and and the
best way to protect ourselves is really
to get vaccinated which prevents us from
getting ill and and from Death so we've
still got a long way to go
we the pandemic has brought to light
vast inequalities with respect to uh
vaccine distribution according to the
World Health Organization vaccination
rates and low-income countries stand at
19 uh compared to almost 75 percent in
high income countries how can this Gap
be overcome yeah I think we have to
think about it right from the start and
when we have new vaccines available we
have to essentially reserve some for
low-income countries it can't be a
pay-to-play market on on vaccines and
vaccination and although there was a
global effort through Kovacs facility uh
Global effort World Health Organization
Gabby and others to try to to try to
correct for that inequality the rich
countries really really got in line
first and a lot of the manufacturing of
vaccines is still based in in high am
income countries which meant that
unfortunately again the higher income
countries came in line first so yeah
less than a quarter of people in
low-income countries have been
vaccinated
now urine immunization expert and you've
been focusing uh one of the things
you've been focusing on is gender
inequality in this whole Matrix has
covet affected women differently than
men and unfortunately or fortunately
women are primarily caregivers they're
the primary caregivers they comprise a
lot of the Primary Health Care Workforce
and women have experienced a double
triple quadruple burden from this
disease they're taking care of their
parents they're taking care of their
children they're going to work and a lot
of women have lost their jobs as a
result or had to leave the workforce so
the the the the the extreme burden on
women during the pandemic has has made
them really disproportionately affected
over men besides and Beyond the
epidemiology also in terms of access to
vaccine coverage women have burden at
home they often work in the informal
settings many of us who work in jobs
vaccines were offered at our workplace
but for women in the informal care
setting or in the informal care
societies they didn't have access to
vaccines in the same way that men did
what would you say are the key lessons
that we've learned from this pandemic
and is do they make us better prepared
for the next one I well we can hope so
and there
and learning right now in Berlin with
over 4 000 experts talking exactly what
we need to do there's going to be a high
level meeting at the United Nations next
year talking about how we can be better
prepared we are we do a lot of work at
the unu University on gender and we
think including women's voices Community
Voices just from the start is one way we
can be better prepared
um putting more women in leadership
levels to think about how to respond to
the pandemic and also making sure and
putting in place waivers for
intellectual property vaccine
manufacturing facilities in low-income
countries there are hundreds of Lessons
Learned and we just need to act on them
inish Welby a principal fellow at the
United Nations International Institute
for Global Health thanks for being with
us today thank you so much